[Music]
there are two ways to come out of yale
for most people they go in liberal and
they leave even more liberal some people
go in conservative and they leave more
liberal and some people
i would put myself in this category go
in kind of conservative and end up to
the right of genghis khan because you
see what is wrong with the american
establishment and the liberal ruling
class
prob one of the most exciting political
candidates on the right right now is
running for senate in ohio his name is
j.d vance you would know him from his
book hillbilly elegy was a best-selling
book became a big movie and talked about
this chasm between the american ruling
class and the the working classes and
the left behind americans and the
deplorables and the irredeemables or
whatever whatever words you want to call
them and jd has gone through a lot of
these
elite institutions and he is running one
of the most populous campaigns in the
country so here to talk about it is jd
vance jd thanks for coming on thanks for
having me so you are
you and maybe a handful of other
candidates blake masters would be one of
them some others as well are being
considered the symbols of the new right
not the same old tired platitudes of the
past 20 years where the most important
thing is just cutting taxes and letting
woke corporations and elites destroy the
country but actually standing up and
doing something about that and bringing
corporations into line rethinking trade
policy rethinking family policy
rethinking all of that
what is the new right to you
yeah you know good good question i mean
uh i probably give five or ten different
answers uh if you gave me long enough
but i mean i i guess basically it's you
sort of alluded to it in the question
which is that we have to rethink the
role
that corporations play in our in our
system of government and our our basic
constitutional republic and we as
conservatives have to wake up to the
fact that for pretty much you know
certainly all of my life
and i think people who are i'm 37 people
even who are much older than i am all of
their life that the republican party the
conservative movement has been the
movement of big business and yet we find
ourselves in a situation where big
business is aggressively and actively
aligned against the things that we care
uh the most about uh they are you know
very much into critical race theory
they're forcing it down the throats of
their employees just the same way that
public schools are forcing it down the
throats of our children uh when states
do pass common sense election reform or
pro-life legislation it is very often
the world corporations that are the
biggest and most aggressive pushbacks
against it and of course and you think
of our most famous and most important
liberty the first amendment right to
free speech
it is corporate america especially the
big technology companies that are the
single biggest threats to that right
unless we actually fight back against
those corporate interests the the
liberties that made this country
worthwhile to live in for two centuries
will slowly disappear and they already
are so if if the biggest enemy of the
squishy ride of the past 20 30 years was
big government big government is the
cause of all problems and any other
institution in the country is
way downstream or not a big threat at
all you're saying that for the new right
the real primary target is big
corporation
yeah i mean i i would say big
corporation working in concert with big
government obviously these things you
know one of the arguments that i would
make is it's very hard to tell
when our woke corporate class stops and
when our woke government class begins
and so when you have somebody like
jinsaki the white house press secretary
threatening facebook with sanctions
unless they censor even more and then
facebook complies
or when you have you know a set of legal
protections in our federal laws that
exist for big technology companies that
exist for no other industry in our
country
or when you see the bide administration
you're pushing a very very expensive
energy policy which of course harms
every single industry except for those
that donate aggressively to the
democratic party wall street and big
tech now you start to realize that like
people like me people like you
your conservatives for a generation have
been taught to think of the government
over here the corporate sector over here
and the what where i think what we've
woken up to is that those two sectors
are very very much aligned it's not even
clear to me in what ways they're
different and we have to reckon with
that fact and frankly fight back against
both right you look at a corporation
like google sometimes the squishes will
say well build your own google
you know google is a private company can
do what it wants first of all google is
not a private company by any stretch of
the imagination the connections with the
government are massive and long-standing
and so we need to rethink that policy so
let's say
your campaign's doing very well pretty
soon we've got senator vance from ohio
what are the
first i i was going to say what are the
first laws you try to pass but there's
more that you can do as a senator so
i'll broaden it even what are the top
priorities for senator vance
yeah i mean i i guess priority number
one even though it's not the subject of
the conversation thus far is you know
when the house is on fire you have to
put out the house fire and i do think
the southern border crisis that we have
is the house on fire moment uh so so
bracket that because that has to be
priority number one you finish the
border wall i think probably double the
number of border enforcement agents that
we have and actually empower those
people to do their job it's actually
really disgusting how the president
united states uh is is so kind to people
breaking the laws but will readily
attack his own employees you know
customs board and border patrol when
they do the job of protecting us from
illegal immigration that's priority
number one i mean to take it back to
this sort of woke corporate thing
you know first of all of course are what
corporations love unlimited cheap labor
they love it for cultural reasons they
love it for economic reasons
but but but to sort of go at them
directly
i think that we we need to do something
uh pretty aggressively to make it easy
for us to break up the big technology
companies
there's an argument that our legal tools
are already there
that the enforcement tools are already
there but i think the fact that they
they're used so sparingly
suggests we're kind of in a moment not
all that different from the one that
teddy roosevelt confronted in the very
early 20th century now a hundred years
later where you have corporations that
are literally more powerful than the us
government which theoretically is the
most powerful entity uh known to man you
know one of my favorite quotes is if you
can silence the king you are the king
and we we learned after january the 6th
that the technology companies have the
ability to silence even very powerful
political leaders like the sitting duly
elected president united states if you
can silence the king you are the king
that's a really important statement
in a republic in self-government the way
you
govern yourself is by speaking by
persuading your fellow citizens so if
some entity in or out of the government
can control all the speech like google
and facebook and twitter can
then they are controlling not just some
aspect of politics but the whole
political order okay so i totally agree
that's number one i like your point too
that whenever people say well you know
just enforce
repeal section 230 liabilities or you
know just enforce antitrust law or
something you say well if it were so
simple we would have done it already it
seems that maybe some further action is
actually required on the point of
immigration though a lot of the liberals
and even the libertarians will say we
need the immigrants we have a dying
population we've got to keep up gdp
we've got to keep paying all those
entitlement programs who's going to fund
my social security and so it is
impossible to reduce immigration
including illegal certainly legal
immigration what say you to that to that
argument
i think we have to reduce both i'd like
you know illegal immigration down to
zero and legal immigration much lower
than the levels that we have it right
now
um you know look our immigration system
is always going to be imperfect but at
the end of the day when you have a dying
population when you have a population
that is not replicating itself which is
true of americans it's true of americans
across
different racial groups then you have a
real problem and you cannot just import
a solution to that problem
when we raise children as part of the
american family we instill certain
values in them we instill certain
expectations in them uh they acquire
certain language and cultural skills uh
that you can't just assume that somebody
who comes here when they're 40 years old
has they just don't it's not their fault
but they but they don't there there is a
real difference between a child that you
raise in your family and someone who
just comes over for dinner right those
are those are two different types of
people uh you don't have to dislike the
guys who come over for dinner but you
can't build a family around them you
have to build a family around the next
generation i think that's how we have to
sort of zoom back and think about our
country and so one i just reject the
idea that you can solve the problem of
demographic decline through immigration
it's it's i think i think it's it's
really really it's frankly sociopathic
to think that that people are
interchangeable like that that that a
child born to an american family is
interchangeable with somebody who comes
in uh from overseas however good their
intentions might be
now then the second thing is you know
one of the crazy things even if we were
to
take their argument at face value one of
the crazy things that happens is when
new immigrants come to this country and
they assimilate well they too start to
have lower fertility rates like there's
something kind of broken
about the american model about the
american structure of society that is
anti-family when you have you know let's
say say a catholic immigrant coming from
latin america
where you'd expect a family to have
three children they get to america and
they have one child there's something
about our society culturally and
economically that's not good for the
raising of children and we have to
address that root cause before papering
over it with immigration reform
absolutely insightful because what
people are going to say is if if you
talk about a dying population you're
sending dog whistles to the white
supremacists everywhere but we're not
you're talking about a nationwide
america problem and you even see it you
even see it in the recent immigrants to
america so then the question is
what do you do about it
you know i i think the one we need to
send a different cultural message from
leaders uh you know
what you want you can do that through
explicit public policy right the
material stuff really does matter you
know victor orban and hungary and other
countries in central and western europe
have actually done a pretty good job of
raising their fertility level russia
actually used to have a major fertility
crisis right but they basically
committed in public policy instead of
having a welfare system basically built
around the single individual they have a
social welfare system that rewards
people for having families for staying
married for doing the things that are
necessary and healthy
from from a family raising perspective
but then you also have a cultural signal
that comes along with that where you
know you look at the way that joe biden
talks about let's say uh his his child
care proposals and it's like well you
know this is so important because we
just need to send those kids to daycare
as quickly as possible so that their
moms and dads can get back into the
workforce look what is the goal of our
society here is it to have healthy
families or is it to have drones in a
cubicle at goldman sachs
they're working 90 hours a week their
children are in daycare 90 hours a week
like there's a fundamentally different
social model that modern progressives
have imposed upon this country they've
done so quietly but we can push back
against that on the right so long as we
have the courage to do it you
unfortunately you do have chamber of
commerce style conservatives say you
know it's it's a it's a really terrible
thing uh when a young mother takes three
years off of work to care for her young
children it's like really like if that
woman wants to do that why is that a bad
thing isn't it good for people who want
to care for their children to be able to
care for their children the fact that
you know you hear so many conservatives
say we're against social engineering but
they love the social engineering that
takes children away from their families
and puts them into corporate day cares
makes it makes you realize how much of a
joke it all is right it was once widely
understood that the hand that rocks the
cradle is the hand that rules the world
and now we are told by the progressive
left that unless you're doing
spreadsheets all day working for some
guy so that you can get some money so
that your husband can pay some woman to
raise your kid seems kind of inefficient
to me that unless you're doing that
you're wasting your life and throwing it
away and it does seem totally backwards
so you mentioned orban you mentioned
russia and how they have they have had
success despite people claiming to the
contrary they have had success turning
their birth rate problem around so is
the suggestion here that we
pay families to have kids and irk the
libertarians on the right
yeah i mean basically uh that that's
right i mean look we pay families not to
have kids we pay families not to work we
pay families to get divorced you
actually make more money from our social
welfare system if you don't have uh
children so i think in a lot of ways we
have to accept that we're already paying
families to do things it's a question of
whether we're paying them to make good
decisions or we're paying them to make
bad decisions and i'd say staying
married having children is much better
than getting divorced and sitting at
home all day
and that that really to me is the
fundamental issue i actually you know i
i don't think that the goal here is a
massive expansion and the amount of
money that we're spending on social
welfare we actually spend a ton of money
on social welfare we just spend it on
very stupid purposes it's a great great
point there's there is no shortage of
welfare spending in the united states
but you got to you got to look at what
you are incentivizing and there's
there's no neutrality here the program
is going to incentivize one behavior or
another now uh forget about all that
productive stuff for a second let's get
into the nitty-gritty filthy politics
you're in a republican primary for this
senate race what distinguishes you from
your your rival in the primary
i think all the stuff that we're talking
about right i mean i think that you know
most of the people who are running in
the primary are good people uh but
they're fundamentally repeating the same
tired chamber of commerce slogans that
you've heard from republicans for 30 or
40 years uh they're just not going to
talk about the things that we've been
talking about they're not going to
advocate for some of the policies that
i've been advocating for and so my
argument to primary voters uh here in
the state of ohio is look
you can have a good person who's going
to vote the right way 75 of the time
or you can have a person who actually is
fighting against the corporate oligarchy
the government oligarchy that's making
it impossible for normal americans to
live their lives and so i really am
trying to make the campaign about you
know what do we want to be as a party
here in ohio what kind of person do we
want to send to washington d.c do we
want to send her a chamber of commerce
type or do we want to send a guy who's
going to fight back against those people
because what we had been told for
decades is that republicans need to get
out of the social issues republicans
need to just just focus on lowering
taxes people vote with their wallet
that's all that really matters and uh
i guess the last five years have kind of
blown that out of the water when donald
trump walked down the escalator calling
illegal aliens rapists and murderers and
some are good people he obviously was
running a culture war campaign and it
seemed to work certainly worked the
first time you saw a cultural campaign
in virginia flip that governorship so
how are you feeling beyond your own
senate race for the republican party
generally as this battle for the soul of
the republicans wages how are you
looking at the chances in 2022 and 2024
for republicans
you know very optimistic about our party
in 2022 24 i think that you know people
just had enough right things have gotten
so crazy
they're they're they're finding out that
their kids are learning crazy stuff at
school they're being forced to sit
through ridiculous trainings at work
where they have to you know disavow
their whiteness like some sort of weird
satanic religious ceremony i mean people
are just like really really fed up with
how insane things have gotten and yeah
you know
there's definitely some pushback i would
say from the institutional powers in the
in in sort of the conservative movement
you know the club for growth i think one
of the worst organizations on the right
has spent two million dollars against me
attacking my primary uh candidacy
because i believe that we should impose
tariffs uh on on on on companies that
make things in china so you know there's
definitely a battle to be had and i
won't pretend that i know
you know we're going to win over a two
to four year period but if you look at
all the people that are running if you
look at where the energy is i feel very
confident that we're going to win this
battle it may take us a little time but
we're going to win the fight there is
this strange fact when you talk about
the tariffs as being somehow
anti-republican that the republican
party was founded on tariffs abraham
lincoln the first republican president
said give me a tariff i'll give you the
greatest nation on earth
it was the party of economic protection
then it became
this free trade party
how did that happen what i mean talk
about you always hear about how the
parties switched how did that happen why
did why did the gop flip and why is it
flipping back now
you know i i think what happened is that
some of the biggest businesses in our
country got a little cocky they got a
little overconfident right they didn't
realize that america's industrial power
had been built
by
free enterprise
but also by smart public policy they
thought we could just you know go into
china hand off all of what made america
great and powerful and just ex
expect that america would somehow make
up for it somehow but that that was
always left as a big question right we
were always supposed to you know the
china would make the rubber duckies uh
we would make the tvs and then china
would make the tvs and we'd make the
advanced robotics
but they were both stealing the
technology on one end and stealing the
rubber ducky factories on the other hand
and the american middle class and
frankly our national greatness got
squeezed in the process uh so i i think
a lot of us just we got fat and lazy
right we were the think about america
1963
was without question the most powerful
country in the world it looked like
nothing could possibly challenge us
um and i and i think that we forgot that
that greatness came from two centuries a
very very wise leadership from our
private sector from our public sector uh
we've got to get back to that and we're
going to lose the country and i think at
least you know i'll say this we're
waking up to the fact that we have been
failed for two generations now in this
country
speaking of elite institutions you you
have done an amazing thing jd which is
you've been through a handful of elite
institutions and have not been totally
cast into the outer darkness where
there's wailing and gnashing of teeth so
you know yale law school graduate had a
very successful hollywood movie a very
very successful book obviously
can the institutions be saved i'll put
it very bluntly shall conservatives go
in and reclaim yale or do we just need
to defund it knock it down and build a
new college in its place
yeah i mean i think you have to go
institution by institution but with yale
in particular i think that uh you know
we need to do a little renovation
by arson um you know i i uh i actually
read this this interesting article over
the weekend it was by helen andrews who
who who's the editor of the american
conservative and you know she was just
talking about how you know for our
entire history we had this sort of
certain understanding of the civil war
and reconstruction and then that all
started to change in our academic
departments and i and i saw a tweet of a
history professor at yale i guess helen
also went to yale and like you know i
forget the exact wording the tweet but
it was something like oh if this person
wants to talk about this she should have
at least taken one of my history courses
at yale but these people
are so pathetic
like we
given over the next the leadership of
the next generation to a history
professor who is whining about the fact
that in that a magazine editor didn't
take one of her history courses at yale
like we we should accept that these
people are so drunk on their own power
and the only thing they have really
going right they don't have money you
don't make that much money as a as a
history professor the only thing they
have is the prestige that those elite
institutions give them but they're so
willing to do
they they die to defend that prestige
that sense of social superiority that
they're unwilling to actually do any
critical self-reflection which means i
think we have to get rid of them i mean
they're not serving any useful purpose i
mean
why is it that for the last two years
we've been living in the tyranny of dr
anthony fauci right like what what gave
this person lordship over the united
states of america it is it is honestly a
set of degrees that are hanging on his
wall conferred by elite institutions
that make all of us say well this person
must know what he's talking about
because he has these degrees but he
doesn't right this is the facade this is
the lie of our university system that it
teaches people to be boring and
conventional it doesn't give them real
knowledge it gives them this ridiculous
prestige game that they then inflict on
the rest of our society uh there i i
think the universities are basically
unsalvageable right because what you get
out of those in all the places that dr
fauci went or all the big brand name
universities what you are getting
increasingly is a brand name credential
and an entrance into certain elite
circles if you want to go to goldman
sachs i'm not sure that your degree from
thomas aquinas college or hillsdale is
going to do it a degree from harvard or
princeton is going to do it but but you
would very likely get a more coherent
education at hillsdale thomas aquinas
avenue wherever we're talking about
these handful of conservative schools so
yes the the prestige does have an
incredible amount of value not just
social value but real monetary value you
can get into these clubs you can get
into these places where you could make a
lot of money and so we've got to adjust
those incentives as well i guess one way
to do that
is by winning by winning power and by
wielding power i suspect that's what a
lot of
your senate race and other senate races
is about proving can we go in there can
we attain some political power and can
we use that for the good jd
i wish you the best of luck where can
people find you jdvance.com is the best
place to go they can learn more about
the campaign support us if they're
willing to do so i'm also on twitter
facebook you know all the normal places
you can find political candidates these
days that's great and once this airs i'm
sure i'll hear from all of your primary
rivals yelling at me and demanding that
they can come on as well jd great to be
with you thanks for coming on
thanks michael take care
[Music]
[Music]